the FTX situation just got much worse
and billions of dollars are now hanging
in the balance it's so big that even the
White House has addressed it recent new
news further underscores uh these
concerns and highlights why uh prudent
regulation of cryptocurrencies is indeed
needed wow now I'm going to try to
explain all of what just happened in the
last 24 hours the swirling rumors the
doomers and the Bloomers wait I'm sorry
the Bloomberg allegations and everyone
else's allegations too because when
something this big happens it becomes
difficult to sort through what is
provably true and what is sort of
speculation so where I can I'll be
telling you what I'm sure about and what
I'm not and I'm even going to share some
Insider knowledge I learned from an
Alameda research employee who leaked a
lot of interesting information to me so
let's get into this but first hello from
the future guys uh it's a quick
Interruption to this video to say that a
lot has happened in the last 24 hours
while editing this and a lot of the
information has changed the story like
just basically kept going and so I've
made an entire extra video attached to
the end of this one covering the latest
information
um please forgive me I haven't slept a
lot buckle up though because they're
stolen billions romantic Affairs flights
to Argentina possibly but for now just
enjoy a much more well-rested coffee
Zilla and I will see you in a bit
last time we spoke FTX one of the
biggest crypto exchanges in the world
was in deep trouble and their biggest
competitor binance was planning to buy
them out for a bailout now initially
this was believed to be a short-term
issue only for FTX CZ their competitor
called it a significant liquidity crutch
this basically means FTX had the money
just they didn't have it right now to
make an analogy imagine I owed you cash
but only had gold that's a liquidity
crunch I can't just give you gold I have
to go sell it first but crucially I have
the money it's just locked up now
depending on how hard it is to
immediately sell this small issue can
turn into a very big one which FTX
figured out when five billion dollars in
withdrawals came in one day and they
just didn't have the money and so that's
what this buyout was all about binance
stepped in and said hey we'll cover
their short-term issue in exchange for
buying out their long-term assets for
pennies on the dollar which is a pretty
brilliant move when you consider that
binance's CEO kind have caused the whole
problem in the first place but if you
want to know more about that you can go
watch our last video however I told you
guys in that video that this buyout was
kind of shaky at best because it was
non-binding which meant at any point
binance could just walk away if they
didn't like what they saw and that's
exactly what happened binance recently
said they're walking away from the deal
and that the reason was based around
latest news reports regarding mishandled
customer funds and alleged U.S agency
investigations and this absolutely
ruined ftx's credibility overnight
because all of a sudden the conversation
on FTX turned from liquidity crunch to
insolvency and fraud because look
there's a big difference between the two
liquidity issues is when I don't have
the cash for you right now but I have
the asset somewhere insolvency is when I
don't have the cash and I have nothing
else either so if FTX was illiquid it's
a great deal if FTX is insolvent it's a
nightmare which is why a lot of people
thought binance backed out of the deal
with both Bloomberg and the Wall Street
Journal reporting a multi-billion dollar
shortfall now Finance responded to this
saying that the issues are beyond our
control or ability to help and this is
very bad news for FTX it's bad news for
all of crypto because your average
investor is about to get wrecked not
only that the CEO Sam Beckman freed may
be in a lot of trouble because it turns
out he was lying to everyone when he
said that FTX is fine and that FTX had
funds to cover all client Holdings he
said this basically minutes before
disaster now he has since deleted those
tweets which might be a good idea
because they probably are criminal but
we'll get back to that in a second
because first I want to go back to
binance's earlier statement about
mishandled customer funds what did they
mean by that and how can a crypto
exchange as big as FTX become insolvent
it's it's like hearing that a casino
went insolvance like how did you guys
lose money you win no matter what these
crypto exchanges make money on the fees
whether you win or not whether it goes
up or down they're making money so how
could you have lost billions of dollars
as one of the biggest crypto exchanges
that's the question and this is where
Alameda research comes in so as a quick
explanation spf's Empire is actually
incredibly complicated like way more
complicated than even complicated firms
like this has been compared to the
Lehman Brothers well the Lehman Brothers
corporate structure is way simpler spf's
web of companies is really difficult to
untangle but really there are two
companies that matter the most Alameda
research and FTX FTX is the crypto
exchange we've talked about and Alameda
research is a small trading firm now
these two companies though they're
technically distinct entities have
always been sort of unusually close some
have speculated unethically close but
their CEO claims that indeed they are
separate entities but with FTX seemingly
becoming insolvent that relationship is
now under scrutiny and it turns out they
may have shared more than enough office
they may have shared information and
also been sharing client funds and this
is where this whole mishandled client
funds allegation comes in because FTX
told users that their digital assets
belong to them and wouldn't be traded
it's explicitly laid out in their terms
of service quote you control the digital
Assets in your account FTX trading does
not represent or treat digital assets in
user's accounts as belonging to FTX
trading and title to your digital asset
Shell at all times remain with you but
turns out this wasn't the case at all
because according to an Alameda research
employee who came to me anonymously
apparently they had more access to FTX
than previously disclosed in fact not
only did they have access to ftx's back
end they managed withdrawals for FTX and
had a giant line of credit that they
could draw on which seems like partially
may have been users funds something that
no separate entity would normally have
now bear in mind that that is coming
from one employee but it's backed up by
another source The Wall Street Journal
who reported that FTX extended loans to
Alameda using money that customers had
deposited on the exchange for trading
purposes which they just said they
wouldn't do quote it was a decision that
Mr bankman freed described as a poor
judgment call but I would disagree with
Mr Sam bankman freed I would not
describe that as a poor judgment call a
poor judgment call is showing up to a
zoo meeting looking like this when you
take clients funds and do exactly what
you told them you would not do with them
that's theft and that is fraud now I
know this is already all insane but
we've only explained sort of half the
story how clients funds were being used
by Alameda but how were they lost
because new reports show that Alameda
May owe FTX 10 billion dollars how did
they lose that 10 billion because these
were supposed to be the crypto Geniuses
right well this is unfortunate currently
where we have to kind of get a mix of
facts and speculation as I said I'm
going to tell you guys what we're sure
about what we're not so losses likely
come from four places that I've heard
about number one is just FTX themselves
spending insane amounts on Advertising
with stadiums Tom Brady and a crazy
number of YouTube influencers who
apparently were Shilling FTX the second
place they likely lost money was that
Alameda invested heavily into ftt tokens
and a lot of their own projects which
when FTX went down basically went to
zero or at minimum couldn't be sold very
quickly the third way they lost money
was that Sam bankman free tried to bail
out all of crypto in the summer people
like block 5 Voyager digital Sky Bridge
Capital which led to huge losses and
then when Alameda found itself with big
losses around the time of a lot of these
companies collapse number four Alameda
took out a four billion dollar line of
credit from Ft x a four billion dollar
loan essentially and what did they give
FTX in return to back up this money ftt
tokens and Robin Hood shares guys which
the FTC tokens is the crazy part because
FTX that's their token so it's basically
giving nothing this is all according to
Reuters and and it's just insane many
Financial commentators are calling this
dark magic but I think Matt Levine of
Bloomberg put it best he says it's
possibly illegal and it's like a bank
lending a lot of money against its own
stock the problem obviously being that
if you face a liquidity crunch or people
lose confidence in you then these ftt
tokens go to zero and now your clients
aren't backed so um it's extremely risky
Behavior at the best and like you said
possibly illegal I'd say probably
illegal so it was this incestuous
relationship between FTX and Alameda
that led to their downfall and while we
don't know the full extent of their
losses and what is just they can't find
the liquidity right now estimates right
now are going from billions to 10
billion dollars at the highest I've seen
which is just wild and I feel so bad for
the victims here but I find the collapse
unbelievably ironic in all of this
because SPF was lecturing Congress about
how crypto exchanges were so much better
than the traditional Financial system in
2008 it was unregulated it was so risky
but it turns out he was doing all of the
same things last thing that I'll say is
if you look at what precipitated some of
the 2008 financial crisis you saw a
number of bilateral bespoke non-reported
uh transactions happening between
Financial counterparties which then got
repackaged and re-leveraged again and
again and again such that no one knew
how much risk was in that system until
it all fell apart if you compare that to
what happens on FTX or other major
cryptocurrency venues today there is
complete transparency about the follow
up in interest there's complete
transparency about the positions that
are held there is a robust robust
consistent risk framework applied and
we're excited to work with the cftc on
our U.S license and regulated venue
yikes does the phrase bespoke
non-reported transactions happening
between Financial counterparties which
then got repackaged or repackaged again
and again to such an extent that no one
knew how much risk was in the system
does that sound familiar to anyone
because it sounds exactly like what SPF
did you know the only difference between
SPF and these Banks which he says were
so bad was that SBF preached us how good
he was he was the generous billionaire
the guy you see next to me is the most
generous billionaire in the world well I
guess that was a lie but we still kind
of have to answer the final question to
all of this which is that it seems like
obviously they're insolvent but how much
of it is insolvency versus liquidity
squeeze we're still figuring that out to
be honest
um SBF even after making a thread today
admitting that he effed up and he should
have done better still claims that FTX
has assets that are higher than their
clients deposits basically saying they
are solvents still kind of but honestly
I think this is almost definitely
another lie from Sam bankman freed given
that a we know that a lot of their
assets are in illiquid tokens like ftt
which their that real value is probably
zero and also B well this guy has
already proven himself to be a liar and
we shouldn't trust him so I just default
to assuming that he's lying uh my guess
is they're insolvent by at least a few
billion maybe the full 10 billion we
don't know SPF is now seeking to raise
9.4 billion in an emergency fundraise
which I think speaks volumes to that I
don't think they'll get it Brian
Armstrong of coinbase has said I don't
know why investors would put money into
this now uh which is a nice way of
saying I don't know why anyone put money
into this ever uh but not everyone
though seems skeptical amazingly there
still are some Believers Bill Ackman for
example believed sbf's apology in a now
deleted tweet he responds that you have
to give SBF credit for his
accountability here I have never seen a
CEO take responsibility as he does here
it reflects well on him and the
possibility of a more favorable outcome
for FTX but what accountability is he
talking about I don't see that at all
SBF is explicitly dodging responsibility
ability about his criminal lies about
reserves remember we talked about how he
said you know assets are fine we have
the full amount clever cover client
deposits but now look at his new
accounting of events because what he
says now is that he messed up and
mistakenly thought that they had zero
leverage and 24x that needed liquidity
in reality he says he was wrong and that
they were leveraged 1.7 x and didn't
have the necessary liquidity and look at
first glance I understand why that would
appear like he's taking you know
responsibility here until you realize
that what he's really telling you is
that he sucks at his job because how can
you not know as the CEO as this genius
how levered up you are you know you're
this genius traitor isn't it awfully
convenient that you're suddenly bad at
your job when it would be criminal if
you actually knew because those are the
two options if he had known he was lying
that's criminal so he's basically saying
well I didn't know I was just wrong I'm
just terrible at my job and I'm just not
buying that my opinion of it is this SBF
is a shark who knowingly put his own
customers funds at risk to save his
trading firm Alameda research he did
this without telling them while giving
them worthless ftt tokens as collateral
which he knew was risky he then lied
about it right up until the last
possible moment and when it finally came
out that what he did was likely criminal
he goes oh oops I didn't know that
things were so bad it's ridiculous and
anyone who believes this well I have a
multi-billion dollar crypto exchange to
sell you anyways he ends this thread by
saying that Alameda research is winding
down trading and he also addresses CZ of
binance saying at some point I might
have more to say about a particular
sparring partner so to speak but you
know glass houses so for now all I'll
say is well played you won which just
strikes me as so weird of a statement he
talks about this as if it's a sparring
partner as if it's all a game this is
not a game to be won and lost this is
billions of dollars colors of people's
real money that you just lost correction
he might have stolen it or maybe one of
his Executives did or a hacker did we
don't know for sure welcome to the
Future it sucks here guys as I said a
lot has changed and I want to cover it
uh for one SPF declared chapter 11
bankruptcy for all his companies
including FTX us which he said was fine
and many influencers promoted uh see
this video for more but it basically
looks like they're all in deep trouble
even worse news around Alameda has
gotten much more dire see originally we
thought this team was a bunch of
geniuses in crypto now it's coming out
they were more like a gang of kids who
all dated each other this report comes
from coindesk Alameda employees were in
romantic relationships with each other
and there's speculation that the CEO of
Alameda Caroline Ellison became the CEO
maybe because she dated Sam bankman
freed incidentally she also has been
revealed to be a big fan of amphetamines
which is just not great when you're
controlling billions of dollars and it
gets worse when you realize that SPF had
secretly added a quote back door into
ftx's bookkeeping system this came out
just recently which allowed SPF to quote
execute commands that could alter the
company's Financial records without
alerting other people in other words
this is how we believe Sam moved 10
billion dollars in funds from FTX to
Alameda without alerting anyone later it
was reported that among this 10 billion
some of it also went missing from even
Alameda with Reuters reporting that one
to two billion dollars are unaccounted
for even among alameda's assets uh which
again it just all looks so bad for SBF
and from here things spiral even worse
because once the dust started settling
you know we thought okay we're gonna get
a clearer picture now that they're
entering bankruptcy but then they
suddenly got hacked in addition to
everything on telegram their admin says
FTX has been hacked all funds seem to to
be gone FTX apps are malware delete them
this is just insane how could this
happen coindesk reported that the hacker
got out 600 million dollars and I have
to tell you that some numbers are
slightly less than that 400 million uh
from slow Mist for example and this hack
is being traced so we don't know the
full story right now but it's a lot of
money so to State the obvious
is very bad for FTX and it also seems
like pretty convenient timing for Sam
who has suddenly become unresponsive so
this fueled a lot of speculation now
Elon Musk decided to join the
speculation seeming to accuse Sam in a
meme of being behind it all he posted
this man F's five million people at once
uh which is a pretty good one and
basically this set off a frenzy of
people frantically trying to unmask the
hacker eager to make it Sam or Caroline
or even their CTO Gary for example some
people use the GitHub activity of Gary
Wang to show that he did an unusual
number of commits to his GitHub repo
basically saying he might have set up
this sudden hack and he did all this a
day before FTX was hacked and this for
sure is very suspicious but we need to
be careful about rushing to conclusions
for example Mario nafal accused the
hacker of being an inexperienced Insider
because some of the funds were traced
back to Kraken and so people thought the
mystery was solved when a kraken
executive said we know the identity of
this user you guys pointed out the
problem was is that it turned out there
were actually two people who were
operating at the time that this hack
happened the hacker and then the
response team over at FTX and the person
using Kraken seems to have been the
response team and not the hacker
themselves so it seems like a false
identification there so I get it we all
want to know who the hacker is but uh we
can't jump to conclusions here and I'm
going to be try to be honest with you
guys about what we know and what we
don't for now let's just say the leading
suspects are anybody at Alameda or FTX
and especially Sam himself but we do not
know for sure another thing we do not
know but people seem to be happy to
claim his fact is that SBF is fleeing
the Bahamas and flying to Argentina this
could be true we just do not know
currently the most tracked flight in the
world is the one everyone suspects of
being Sam but we do not have concrete
evidence and that's going to be the
final bit of speculation we entertain
here because there's infinite theories
about how all this happened all we know
is that FTX is massively in debt and
users are unlikely to get their funds
back because they sent A lot of it to
Alameda and seem to have lost it somehow
the most recent report based on the
bankruptcy filing shows FTX held less
than a billion dollars in liquid assets
against 9 billion in liabilities so this
whole is just so bad at this point and I
think that was actually pre-hack so the
real story is likely a lot more grim and
this has been a sad case study
entrusting slick billionaires too
quickly and I think this story is only
just getting started anyways I hope that
keeps you up to date and hopefully we
can edit this thing before all of this
information goes out of date in three
hours thanks for watching and it's time
for me
to get some sleep